There are at least
56 million kilometers
standing between
us and Mars.
That’s a long
way to travel.
♪♪
But what if there
was something
that could help?
An untapped force,
all around us.
That could give
us an extra push.
I'm Wrenn Schmidt and we're
exploring the science
behind "For All Mankind."
With a journey to Mars
heating up between NASA,
Helios and the Soviet Union
we wanted to
create a thrilling
come from behind surprise.
What could give
someone an unexpected
edge in this
literal space race?
The answer led us
into the light.
Light is made up of photons.
Photons don’t have any mass.
But they do have momentum.
A single photon
soaring through space
can't do much.
But, the sun
pumps out trillions
of photons
per second.
And all these photons
in zero gravity
well, they can
pack a punch.
(ping pong balls dropping)
♪♪
So...
how can we
harness them?
We need something
large and reflective.
Something that can
bounce light.
A solar sail made of
Mylar can do just that.
♪♪
The photons bouce off the
reflective sail,
transferring their momentum,
pushing the ship forward.
More photons means
more momentum.
The impact may be
small, but it's steady.
It’s a little boost that
can really add up.
To push a ship as
big as NASA's Sojourner
you need a
really big sail.
Making a sail that big
would be challenging
and the bigger the sail,
the more fuel you'd
need to launch.
But a ship with a
large enough sail
could ride the sunlight
all the way to Mars.
Riding Photons
through space
may sound like fiction,
but it's science.
Scientists are currently
exploring how the use
of lasers and thinner,
lighter materials
could open up new
possibilities.
Even now there is a
toaster-sized space craft
orbiting the Earth
by solar sail.
Well, solar sails that
could propel a ship
as massive as
Sojourner
aren't reality
just yet.
A future of
space exploration
fueled by the Sun is certainly
a powerful idea.